hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild game from the 1990 Goldberg
Memorial it's a game from two
international masters from Russia
you can even Yamina which Callaghan and
Sergei you far off and it's really a
game that belongs
well nowhere else but in the sorcery
series if you are new to the channel you
might not know what the sorcery series
is it it's a playlist I have a new tube
that has I don't even know how many
videos I think seven and they're like
games that belong nowhere else there is
so so crazy games that you just don't
know if they're actually real or not and
this is one such game that was suggested
to me by a subscriber and I thought yeah
we haven't done a sorcery game for a
while now and this is just just the
candidate so without further ado let's
check it out Evgeny opens with E 4 we
have C 5 the Sicilian defense is on the
board sorry about that and if you guys
are interested in watching some other
games from the sorcery series I will put
a link in the description below with the
sorcery playlist it's some seven videos
so I feel free to check it out and if
you're wondering where is all the hair
Jelena was kind enough to give me a
haircut so yeah and now and now I look
like this hope you enjoy that as well
and Knight to f3
so just nicely continuing to develop we
have d6 and Bishop to b5 which checked
the canal attack Bishop to d7 and we
have a captures captures captures with
castles this is all very standard stuff
Knight to c6 c3 preparing to strike in
the center with d4 but first black
attacks the e4 pawn Knight f6 and now
you could go for a timid move like rook
to e1 or d3 to defend your e4 pawn
however the favorite weapon for four
players with the white pieces is the
Bronstein gambit with the d4 you offer
the e4 pawn and what's the idea before
behind offering the pawn well black
always characters it with knight
characters on e4 and now d5 you just
grab more space in the center and if
black doesn't want to have his pawns
doubled with captures and captures like
this he has to go back with the knight
which is what you fear of goes for with
Knight the b8
and this game was played in 1990 I
couldn't find photos of these two
gentlemen now from 1990 so I had to use
a modern photos of them but you know
yeah we use what we can
we've looked the one now attacking the
night here and night back to f6 followed
by Bishop to g5 and now black has to
decide how to develop it the night here
and in in modern chess this disposition
does arise and the nice - a6 is the mood
that you will play here Knight is 60
then you can shift the night over to c7
but in this game quinta f5 was played
freeing up the d7 square for for the
night it this way and also it's a nice
square for the Queen however white
replies with Bishop captures an f6
making it a problem for Bela for black
to recapture with the Queen if you
capture with the Queen then Queen b3 is
the problem the Queen from f5 no longer
has access to the CA square you have to
play b6 to guard your pawn and then it's
between b5 check 97 Queen here goes
after the rook rook has the block
somewhere rugby 8 or d8 and then you go
night a3 you go after b5 to go for c7
but then a 6 but again tonight the c4
with the threat of Knight captures here
all in all black will just blacks
position will just be become terrible
and well very soon deteriorate so after
Bishop characterized that you cannot
capture with the e pawn since it's
pinned by the rook on e1 so g characters
on f6 and now you have to continue
development with white you already gave
up some material so how do you continue
with Knight the a3 probably is best then
you shift your knight over to see -
maybe to e3 and so on as the Queen needs
to keep an eye on the d5 pawn but if
Knight the a3 was played it's for well
now chances are this game would never
have made it into the sorcery series but
in this game Knight B to d2 was played
going for a more rapid development but
also giving up the pawn here so what's
the idea behind this pawn sacrifice
well black captures that black is also
very interested to figure out what the
idea is and now c4 just grab
grabbing more space in the center the
queen is very happy to go back we have
Queen back to c6 and now comes Knight to
e4 and already White has some very
dangerous threats for example if you're
not careful it's a 97 already you get
Knight captures on d6 check if you
capture you just lose the Queen since
the pawn is pinned and if you go here
let's say captures you lose the rook so
black has to be extremely careful black
goes King to d8 which is in fact the
strongest move by the engine just
unpinning and now before white just
continues that to push forward the
threat is just captures as now the D
pawn is also pinned by the Queen so C
characters on before but now c5 white is
just pushing forward we have d5 of
course not allowing this push and now
Knight to d4 kicking back the Queen we
have Queen to d7 and now of course you
can imagine c6 white is just a
relentless attack here you could capture
with the knight but black decides to
capture with the b-pawn so the center is
immediately strengthened but again night
the c5 now and those Knights are one
step closer to the black king by every
move we have Queen back to e8 and now
there is a problem for white here if
black is able to get a 5 then black
black will most likely be okay for
example if Queen f3 and you allow 5 then
this is a massive Center sure white is
better but if black is able to
consolidate let's say rook c1 you're
gonna go Bishop to e7 now even this is a
threat it's hard to say how white white
continues here so white had a genius
idea let's simply prevent a black from
playing a 5 by playing rook the e6 and
by playing rook takes 6 we've prevented
e5 and it's not easy for black to make a
move here well unless the obvious move F
captures on e6 but unless you don't want
to capture it's really not that easy
nuts the captured rook for example if
you try to continue development let's
say Bishop h6 then there's a double
attack here
so now just Knight captures on c6 Knight
captures and Queen captures on d5 with
check and now the the game just falls
apart for
96 check King goes to b6 you have to
keep an eye on the night here and now
just a for with Queen to be five mates
to follow or black will have to suffer a
severe material loss so after work to e6
you fir have decided that there is no
other move let's simply capture the roof
so f captures on e6 and now Knight D
captures a nice text width
check leaving black the black King with
only one square which is King to c8
which of course was played King to c8
and the now comes Queen to g4
threatening all sorts of nasty
discoveries and now black finds the only
good move for black and that's why this
game is so beautiful because both white
and black pretty much played the only
moves that that allow the game to be to
be this great a5 and what this does is
it says you don't have you don't have
any great discoveries here the problem
is for example if you become greedy and
go Knight to g7 with check hoping that
you're gonna pick up the Queen as the
night also guards the d7 square problem
is black has f5 attacking your queen and
once you capture that now comes East 6
and now you can either trade Queens or
you can move the Queen and then just
lose the knight on g7 and well yeah it
was regarding how much material you've
sacrificed you do not want to trade
Queens or giving up give up more
material for no reason
so instead after a 5 white played the
absolute strongest Knight captures and I
fate delivers a check this way we have
f5 again this is a must
Queen captures with a 6 now now forcing
the White Queen to move or Knight
captures an d6 again threatening a lot
of nasty discoveries so black blocks it
Knight to d7 and here you have to
continue the attack with white how do
you how do you proceed well rook a to C
1 or just work to c1 a silent but deadly
move as it brings the rook into the game
on the same file as the king so here
black catches a moment to take his
breath maybe he can do something here
best for black is probably something
like Queen to e7 which is hard to even
consider
in a moment like this but let's say the
normal night characters on c5 instead of
let's say rope capture the night captors
you open up a discovery here kink the c7
and now Queen to f4 check King b6 you're
gonna go Queen to d4 and it's now a
question whether black can survive this
or not
with perfect play probably as in in
practical game most likely not but it
would be a decent try however in the
game looked a 7 was played and now white
finds another another beautiful move
so even feel free to pause the video and
try to find this the only way to give Y
to the advantage here in this game while
I give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on spotting that it's
time to give up even more material and
that is Knight to e4 now the thread is
Knight to d6 check which will win win
Blacks Queen as it comes with a fork so
you have to capture it not capturing is
not an option because if you try to move
the King was taking b8 then its Queen f4
check you're gonna get King to a8 and
now Knight to the c7 with again with a
fork you have to give up your rook
characters captures and now yes you win
the night and now you wrap a piece but
rook captures on c6 and there is no
defense against rook to a6
that's the problem for example if not be
hated then you just go Queen captures on
a5 King here and now rook to c7 will be
made so after Knight to the e4 you frog
really doesn't have much to choose on he
decides to capture the night but now
it's a pretty similar tactic rook
captures on c6 width check and now King
tabby it came to b7 then you're inviting
Queen to b5 checking gate and again we
go into the same line 97 check character
Scouters and you are again getting made
it not nothing for you to do here so
King to be it instead of King to b7 but
now it's Queen to f4 check and the we
again and enter that same same line so
King the b7 is a possibility again then
you run into rook to c7
but it would give it would perhaps give
black a bit
or breathing room however black
Wednesday 8 and here we have 97 check
rook captures we have Queen captures on
c7 now with the threat of roof day sex
checkmate nights to be 8 preventing that
but now white just went in for the kill
Queen captures on a5 King to be 7 and
now rook the c7 with checkmate so really
really a wild game I I do hope you you
consider it fit for the sorcery series I
really do as it's just been after that
branch 10 gambit d4 is just you know
uh-uh-uh-uh-uh-uh a bolt from the clear
with every move and it was just very
enjoyable to watch so I really really
enjoyed it myself
i I do hope you enjoyed it as well I
would like to thank Philip Becker Dmitri
often again then a William Avery
James score cut and Nicolas Peltier for
further contributed to my channel thank
you a lot - really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here I think all for watching and
I will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the morphe saga checking up
on a Lua hs0 in stockfish checking up in
a wonderful suggestions such as this
game here and whatever else happens in
the chess world so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day and do check out the other
games from the source of sorcery series
the first link in the description below
see you soon